it's a samurai anybody speak Japanese
nothing um okay Takeda tell me he did
not just speak Japanese I can do things
why do you worry why nothing these
goodies amore what I so I'm leaving
central see where where are you going
I'm gonna go stay with a friend then
blue value for a while ever here has
their own journey appears us taking you
on a new path
you owe it to yourself to go
[Music]
how's Blue Valley Oh self-reflection and
the battle with a starfish from out of
space if you respect so you found what
you were looking for I don't know to be
honest well we are glad you're home
looks like you found the guy behind the
bus medicine so you want to suit up take
him down no no it's his move I think we
take our time formulate a plan no why
you can make it he's done Blue Valley
can't believe Happy Holidays everybody
so I've gotten a couple requests for
special Easter egg videos naturally
we're talking about wall-e going to
Titans maybe so I figured this would be
a good video to do during this time of
the year but because it's the holidays
I'm also doing a new round of that flash
ring giveaway so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything
probably the biggest one is the Storrow
Easter Egg so a lot of people are
thinking Justice League but Kid Flash
was actually a member of the Titans it
was just that it was Bart Allen who was
the member because it was the Jeff Johns
run but because they're changing things
in the air overs in Jeff Jones is
teasing things from his run they're just
mixing and matching a lot of things from
different eras so finding a starfish
from outer space
Starro in Blue Valley is an Easter Egg
for the Titans of tomorrow story art
during volume three
now the actual cover is from issue
number 52 but that was like part two of
this time travel story where the Titans
of today were fighting the Titans of
tomorrow who had become the Justice
League
so Tim Drake who was the Robin of Teen
Titans at the time was fighting his
older self who had taken the mantle of
the bat Miss Martian was also on that
team she was fighting her old herself
who had taken the mantle of Martian
Manhunter so it was sort of like the
Justice League of tomorrow made up of
the older versions of Teen Titans
characters who'd come back in time to
change the past to bring about this
totalitarian state so there was a lot of
eye winking at the Teen Titans becoming
the Justice League eventually so they
paid a lot of homage to Justice League
Easter eggs like brave and the bold
fighting starfish like the first big
Justice League team up so the Teen
Titans TV show is going with more of an
original Teen Titans vibe - the cyborg
character because he was part of that
original roster they're just borrowing
from a lot of things that happened
during Jeff Jon's run when we actually
started getting Titans episodes next
year that I'll explain where Easter eggs
are from during different comic book
runs the second big one that Cambodia
one is actually rose Wilson ravager the
thing to remember like I keep talking
about this Jeff Jones roster Rose Wilson
was a member of the Teen Titans during
Jeff Jones run the reason why Cambodia
is so important is is because that's
where she was born that's where her
mother was from Slade Wilson was sent
down there to help this woman who became
Rose Wilson's mother during
Deathstroke's solo title it was
Deathstroke number 15 he was sent down
to Cambodia to rescue someone called
sweet Lily who he sort of fell in love
with had a liaison Rose Wilson was the
product of that what happened is his
death stroke got divorced from Adeline
Kaine who's the mother of Grant Wilson
who we met in the arrowverse as well as
Jericho who just got that storyline
during the arrow episodes this season he
was hired to go to Cambodia on a rescue
op for this person called sweet Lily
they totally did the deed Lily kept the
baby a secret from Deathstroke
eventually she went to New York grew up
and then Billy wintergreen learned about
the child and thought that it might be
Deathstroke's daughter during a separate
story line called Deathstroke the hunted
then about 10 years after that she
became a much more mainstream character
joined the Teen Titans at the beginning
of vol 3 in the rest is history
Wally speaking Japanese during episode 1
is a bit of a meta Easter egg there's a
bunch of different things happening here
so one it's an easter egg for the flash
number 180
where was the Barry Allen version of the
flash from the Silver Age fighting
samurais that had been created by Baron
katana like Wally gets hoisted up with
the katana while he's wearing Barry
Allen's suit but it's also an eye wink
at the Teen Titans anime
that was actually a cartoon that has his
origins in anime when they were
envisioning it they wanted to market to
very young kids and at the time Japanese
anime was super popular so you had a
bunch of traditional Western animation
cartoons that you would see on cartoon
network or the Disney Channel that were
emulating anime
so with a lot of these Easter eggs you
can see that there are i winking at
titan stuff even though I'm convinced
that wall-e will probably not go on
Titans during season 1 what will
probably happen is is they'll keep
wallet in the arrowverse proper just
because those four shows are a little
more organized than the new stuff that's
happening they'll get their figured
out with Titans they'll introduce their
core roster and the other big characters
that they've already confirmed like Hawk
and Dove Donna Troy might be coming on
there's just so many big characters from
the classic Teen Titans comics that he
usually winds up being a nightmare when
you just throw too many characters on
screen at once without developing them
all so I think they're gonna try and
play it safe with the way that they
introduce characters to that show
because pretty much any of the
arrowverse characters could cross over
to that because there have been so many
crossovers in the comics you know with
the new titan show coming and the
mention of Bruce Wayne on air today
is there any chance we'll see the Titans
show in the air overs and if not we see
any air overs characters on the Titan
show a great question again above my
paygrade the one thing I will say this
the one thing I've learned is Never Say
Never
I could not begin to tell you how often
we say to each other like we never
thought any of this was gonna happen we
never thought we'd see all these
characters we never thought there'd be
like a universe so I never say never but
in terms of like which characters can be
on which shows and what's part of the
universe above my paygrade and probably
that's a good so that's why you see a
lot of these TV shows just i winking at
really big things like arrow just
introduced the idea of Bruce Wayne it's
not necessarily them saying that we're
gonna introduce that character during
this season it's just them laying the
groundwork for a big character reveal
and him to eventually enter the
arrowverse in some way they just haven't
quite figured out how they're gonna
accomplish that but in the meantime they
can make all the references they want so
there is an intelligent design behind
all these shows crossing over but a lot
of times like with these Wally West
Titans Easter eggs it's just them having
a little bit of fun so most of the
writers that are writing these things on
all the shows don't have any say in
whether or not characters cross over on
TV shows that involves a lot of
contractual step behind the scenes that
only the perdu
users get involved in in the
powers-that-be so what'll happen is
we'll just watch Wally West and see how
many more Titans Easter eggs they drop
this season and see if it gives us any
clues about where he's going because in
the short term there's a lot of more
likely candidates for where he could go
inside the arrowverse they have a lot
more control over the four shows that
are confirmed arrowverse than they do
over the new stuff like black lightning
or Titans technically they're all
Berlanti verse but because all the shows
are supposed to feel very very different
like Black Lightning isn't gonna
crossover with arrow the flash right
away neither is Titans they're just
gonna do their own thing then eventually
they'll figure out how they're gonna
cross the characters over but of all the
Wally West Easter eggs this season for
him doing other big Justice League
Titans stuff which one is your favorite
and what will happen is is they'll be
much more DC this week just leave all
your requests in the comments below I'm
working on some new Deadpool that should
post in a couple hours there's a new
round of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on the video
congratulations to the winner from my
last video David Wain please private
message me so I can get your contact
details I'll name a new winner when I
post new DC but click here for brand new
flash season 4 and click here for the
new Black Panther a Christmas trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight